David, why do you think Christian profits
are on the rise again?
This is a really interesting question.
And there's a super compelling article in
The New York Times about Christian prophets
and their predictions.
And one of the points that the article makes
is that right now there is a real hunger for
reassurance and clarity in many areas of American
culture.
In particular, we have seen Donald Trump be
the least popular president by approval rating
in the polling era.
Leave the White House with the lowest approval
rating of any president in the polling era,
with so many failed promises from Donald Trump.
And for the left who never believed any of
that stuff to begin with and on average is
less religious than the right.
And to the extent that the left is religious,
it tends to be less the sort of charismatic
evangelical Christianity that is so much more
prominent on the right in the United States.
The left isn't really looking for prophecy,
for reassurance and clarity, because much
of the left never believe Trump to begin with.
And much of the left doesn't look to these
sort of televangelist equivalents for guidance
on the right, you saw an initially resistant
evangelical Christian wing of America resist
Trump at the beginning, sort of get behind
Ted Cruz and some other candidates in the
2016 Republican primary.
Eventually, Trump won and they certainly weren't
going to vote for Hillary Clinton.
So you saw a lot of these folks who would
not normally go for the multiple times divorced
guy who pays off of porn stars and whatever
else, OK, they went with him and then everything
he promised he didn't do.
Now some of them just continue to insist he
did all of it.
He was the most pro-life president in all
of this different stuff.
But many of them now are seeking some kind
of reassurance and clarity after seeing Trump
not do any of the stuff he promised to do
and then lose to Joe Biden, who, despite actually
being more devoutly religious than Donald
Trump, is Catholic and is a Democrat, which
does not go too well for a lot of these charismatic
and evangelical Christian communities.
So there's a big demand for someone who will
tell you in clear terms, here's what's going
to happen.
And that is part of the reason why Christian
prophets are sort of seeing this resuscitation.
The newly popular, once again, widely making
wrong predictions, as has always been the
case.
Now, interestingly, astrology is also expanding
in popularity and the number of Americans
who believe in psychics are also expanding.
And I think that this is just a general sort
of reaction to uncertain political times,
combined with a global hundred year pandemic
and the desire to have someone who will tell
you, here's how things are going to be in
your life, in the political future of the
United States, etc..
We know that at minimum, one third of Americans
say that they're suffering from stress and
anxiety as a result of the pandemic.
When we ask when will it be over, we don't
really know.
We're starting to get more clarity, at least
on the trajectory over the next few months.
And things are looking better and hopefully
it'll keep going that way.
But for a year now, we've had such uncertainty
that it is natural that people would want
answers and they would want someone who will
tell you definitively who is more arrogant
in their predictions than these particular
televangelist type Christian prophets whose
income and.
Livelihood depends on even if they don't know
what the hell's going to happen, telling you
that they definitely do.
And because of that, I'm not particularly
surprised that this world of Christian punditry
and prophecy has surged in popularity.
If I'm missing something in that analysis,
let me know.
I'm curious to hear from you.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Make sure you get instant access by becoming
a member at Join Pakman dot com.
We will see you then.